[Musique]
voilà je suis là devant vous Hannut je
décide aujourd'hui de partager avec vous
ma découverte je suis vulnérable je suis
femme je suis Agathe Agathe enchanté
vous vous me rencontrez aujourd'hui moi
je me suis rencontrée il y a 4 ans
il y a quatre ans j'ai entrepris un
voyage mon voyage intérieur
mais avant de vous compter ce
merveilleux voyage remontons tout
d'abord le temps à l'époque de la petite
Agathe
je suis une petite fille sociale joviale
et curieuse et pourtant j'ai la tête
remplie de questions et
d'incompréhension sur mon histoire et
celle de ma famille
je décide de les mettre de côté et
de me dire ce n'est pas grave et
d'avancer je suis une adolescente
rebelle avec énormément de colère en moi
et je ressens une immense tristesse à
l'intérieur de moi-même
et je sens que c'est lié à ses
incompréhensions qui trottent dans ma
tête depuis toutes ces années en fait je
les comprends toujours pas et je me suis
pas suffisamment à l'aise d'en parler
librement parce que personne autour de
moi n'en parle ouvertement vous savez
c'est fameux non dit
à ce moment-là d'ailleurs je vis de
plein fouet de nouvelles
incompréhensions comme j'aime les
appeler à cette époque et ça
s'intensifie je garde tout en moi et de
nouveau je répète ce schéma qui est de
me dire aller Agathe oublie le passé
avance avance
je deviens donc une jeune fille une
jeune femme qui a soif de découverte et
je pars m'installer pour vivre pour la
première fois toute seule en métropole à
Paris à 19 ans et je décide de
croquer la vie à pleines dents et
d'oublier l'avant enfin je décide c'est
plutôt mon inconscient qui décide de
d'oublier l'avant moi Agathe j'y vois
que du feu
c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment là que je
pars vivre dans plusieurs pays étrangers
alors d'abord l'Inde je tombe
immédiatement amoureuse de ce pays puis
ensuite le Brésil et là waouh que de
joie de vivre malgré cette misère qui
est prégnante et là-bas j'y retrouve des
valeurs que j'ai d'ailleurs aussi
retrouvé en Inde qui sont ces valeurs de
partage et d'ouverture à l'autre et moi
ça me à cette époque là ça me passionne
et ça me saisit et puis je vais vivre
aux États-Unis et alors clairement la
vie là-bas elle était pas faite pour moi
j'ai d'ailleurs souvent dit que c'était
une expérience beaucoup moins bonne que
les autres mais en fait c'est faux
parce qu'ils sont nés passés des choses
là-bas des choses qui ont bouleversé ma
vie
c'était donc il y a 4 ans et demi voire
bientôt même cinq ans début 2018 je pars
m'installer aux États-Unis pour y vivre
un semestre et comme d'habitude je me
fais une bande de potes mais cette
fois-ci il y a quelque chose qui ne me
convient pas dans ses relations je
trouve qu'elle manque d'authenticité et
de profondeur et
il y a seulement une relation qui se
dégage du lot c'est quelqu'un avec qui
je peux parler de tout et de rien avec
bienveillance et sans jugement ce
constat là de ces relations qui manque
d'authenticité ça me ça me peine
beaucoup et je me questionne sur
moi-même
je me sens soudain très seul
et je fais ces constats qui sont que
tout d'abord je comprends que j'ai
refoulé énormément de choses de mon
passé pendant toutes ces années
qu'ensuite je prends très peu de temps
pour moi que je suis constamment dans
l'attente de quelque chose sans savoir
vraiment quoi que je répète un schéma
dans mes relations amoureuses voire même
amical mais je le fais pas exprès et que
je suis constamment à
vouloir sortir comme si je suis quelque
chose et que je voulais pas me retrouver
seul c'est le constat en fait que je
suis constamment vers l'extérieur mais
jamais vers l'intérieur c'est à dire
moi-même
ce constat il me mène à une grande
introspection sur ma jeune vie et sur
mon passé
là vous voyez tous ces moments du passé
toutes ces incompréhensions ces
questions que j'avais décidé de mettre
de côté ou de les oublier elle revienne
elle rejaillissent tout d'un coup tout
en surface au même moment sa Pope comme
ça tous les côtés et alors vous pouvez
le deviner et je peux vous le dire
c'était hyper intense c'est comme si je
les revivais tous pour la première fois
de nouveau mais tout en même temps c'est
très difficile et je pleure quasi
quotidiennement seul cette fois-ci dans
ma chambre
c'est pour ça que quand je retourne
m'installer à Paris je prends une grande
décision
la décision de
mener une thérapie avec une
psychothérapeute je n'ai plus envie de
mettre de côté ces incompréhensions ce
fameux pourquoi
j'ai parce que quoi qu'il arrive elle
revienne constamment même des années
après je j'ai besoin de comprendre et je
sens à ce moment-là de ma vie
j'ai un profond mal être en moi et
que j'ai certainement quitté caché
depuis toutes ces années mais là cette
fois-ci il est là il transpire en moi et
je sens qu'il va pas partir de si tôt
c'est donc en septembre 2018 que je
commence ma psychothérapie avec Isabelle
une psychologue spécialisée en
psychotraumatisme lors de cette première
séance du coup avec Isabelle elle me
demande de poser des objectifs
pour m'accompagner dans cette thérapie
un peu comme des axes de travail donc je
décide aujourd'hui de vous les livrer le
premier objectif c'était de
comprendre que je m'étais posé que
c'était de comprendre pourquoi j'avais
ce schéma dans mes relations et de le
stopper le deuxième objectif c'était de
savoir prendre des décisions parce que
alors oui à l'époque faire des choix ça
relevé de l'impossible pour moi et le
troisième objectif c'était que ces
incompréhensions deviennent des
compréhensions
là rapidement Isabelle elle a tout de
suite découvert que j'avais un S PT un
syndrome post-traumatique
de là la thérapie elle s'est tournée
vers une autre format de thérapie plus
adaptée qui s'appelle lycée V
intégration du cycle de la vie cycle de
la vie c'est comprendre que tout évolue
rien n'est figé que le passé appartient
au passé et que le présent il est tout
autre souvent vous savez on entend aller
passer à autre chose oublie le passé
mais moi en fait je dis non il ne faut
certainement pas oublier le passé par
contre oui il faut l'intégrer l'intégrer
à son être parce que si il reste caché
là et ben ces blessures engendrées par
se dit passé elles vont inconsciemment
diriger nos actions et altérer nos
relations je vous parle en connaissance
de cause parce que c'est ce qui s'est
passé moi dans ma vie avant ce travail
sur soi et cette prise de conscience
alors vous vous en doutez un travail sur
soi mon travail sur soi ne s'est pas
fait en un claquement de doigts
il y a eu plusieurs étapes à cette
thérapie la première étape je
l'appellerai colère
colère parce que je pleure beaucoup je
ressens énormément de colère en moi et
je suis énervée contre le monde contre
le monde entier parce qu'en fait à ce
moment-là Isabelle elle met des mots sur
ce que j'ai vécu mon trauma et ma
blessure l'abandon
la deuxième étape je l'appellerai
reconstruction
je me reconstruis voire même je me
construis suite à ces découvertes et
c'est compréhension et c'est d'ailleurs
à ce moment là que je mène les premières
actions concrètes pour créer ma société
karma qui était inexistante à l'époque
et puis le troisième objectif je
pourrais l'appeler de renaissance vous
voyez cette image qu'on entend souvent
de la Chrysalide dans un cocon et la BAM
il y a un papillon qui émerge et ben ce
papillon là cette année c'est moi je je
sens un équilibre je me sens aligné je
découvre la vie ma vie
alors
[Musique]
je me demande mais en fait c'est quoi
être vivant est-ce que c'est tout
simplement se rendre compte que il y a
tout un écosystème mais que le cœur de
cette écosystème c'est d'abord soit
et dès lors que j'ai compris ça c'est
comme si toute ma vie j'avais des
œillères là comme ça et là bam les
œillères partent elles explosent et je
découvre un nouveau monde une nouvelle
sensibilité je m'émerveille devant la
beauté de mon écosystème de la vie vous
savez comme on peut le dire la magie de
la vie où l'âme agit comme on peut
entendre parfois c'est être à
l'intérieur de soi pour s'ouvrir vers
l'extérieur
comprendre qu'on fait partie d'un tout
qu'on fait partie de la nature c'est
comprendre qu'on a une puissance en nous
c'est d'ailleurs ben ce que j'essaye de
transmettre à travers karma ma société
qui est rapidement pour vous expliquer
un lieu de vie qui met en avant la
consommation locale et éthique qui passe
par plusieurs aspects
à savoir la restauration d'abord locale
et bio puis l'artisanat et la culture et
j'en passe en fait la raison d'être de
karma c'est de permettre à chacun
d'interagir positivement avec ce
écosystème c'est à dire soit autrui et
la nature
en fait j'ai envie de
d'offrir ma découverte à travers ce lieu
bienveillant où les gens peuvent se
sentir libre d'être eux-mêmes
sans jugement ou là où ils peuvent se
sentir libre de prendre la parole alors
vous l'aurez compris karma c'est
un peu la résultante de ce premier
travail sur moi
et si je l'ai appelé karma c'est pas
pour rien karma en fait ben c'est le
leitmotiv qui apparu dans ma vie à ce
moment-là c'est comprendre qu'on est
maître de son destin maître de ses choix
mettre de sa vie que on est en constante
et à une évolution tout est en constante
évolution et que rien n'est linéaire
qu'on peut rebondir
alors revenons sur cette notion de
confiance et de puissance en nous un
jour Isabelle elle me dit Agathe tu sais
connaître sa vulnérabilité se montrer
vulnérable être vulnérable c'est une
grande force et c'est ce qui toi te rend
plus forte
et en effet il y a 4 ans j'ai rencontré
ma vulnérabilité
et depuis je me suis jamais sentie aussi
forte
alors je tends un coup d'oeil à la
définition du mot vulnérable dans le
dictionnaire Larousse il est écrit
fragile sensible imparfait attaquable le
contraire de solide
parfait et inattaquable donc de prime
abord ce cette définition elle semble
assez péjorative parce que les mœurs
nous font croire qu'être fragiles
sensibles imparfait c'est mal or non on
est tous vulnérables
on est tous vulnérables
mais on nous apprend à le cacher ou nous
apprend à être fort à être solide aux
yeux de la société
vous savez les injonctions telles que ne
pleure pas on pourrait te croire faible
cache tes émotions on pourrait profiter
de toi endurci toi ne sois pas trop
accessible et j'en passe
elle ne serait que des protections que
l'inconscient créé
alors question nous est-ce que méfiance
rime avec confiance
pour moi la confiance il s'agit de se
dire je ne laisse plus parler mes peurs
je n'ai pas honte je suis moi dans son
entièreté face à moi-même et face au
monde je me sens suffisamment à l'aise
avec moi-même pour me mettre à nu et
être transparente et confiante
vous savez avant je me confiais jamais à
personne personne ne savait que si
vraiment qui j'étais si ce n'est cette
personne qui voyait de l'extérieur la
nana souriante avec une joie de vivre
mais personne ne connaissait la Agathe
cet Agathe avec un mallette profond et
un trauma enfoui mais c'est normal
personne ne pouvait la connaître parce
que elle-même moi-même je ne me
connaissais pas et dès lors que j'ai
permis ma rencontre et ben je partage je
parle je raconte
je libère et j'ai libéré la femme qui
est en moi j'ai découvert la puissance
cette pleine puissance en moi la
puissance qu'est la femme cette femme
que
j'incarne à travers les différentes
générations de femmes de ma famille et
de celle du monde au global je comprends
à présent et je ressens mieux leur
histoire et par ricochet mon histoire je
suis sensible et je suis solide
alors voilà maintenant je peux dire que
je crois en moi parce que j'ai compris
que j'ai les ressources en moi et rien
n'est impossible dès lors qu'on retire
ces croyances limitantes tout semble
vaste et illimité je sais à présent que
je suis capable
capable avec un bac littéraire
d'intégrer une grande école de commerce
alors qu'on nous rabâchait que ce
n'était pas possible capable de
recommencer mes études à zéro après une
errance scolaire de plusieurs années
capable de monter un restaurant avec
aucune expérience en restauration
capable de repenser la vision de la
restauration qui n'est pas que liée au
plaisir mais qui est d'implémenter la
pleine conscience de l'alimentation dans
un restaurant comprendre qu'il y a tout
un impact derrière ce qu'on mange à
savoir sur sa santé l'environnement
et la société
alors voilà je me mets à nu aujourd'hui
devant vous et c'est plein de gratitude
que je vous annonce qu'il y a un mois ma
thérapie avec Isabelle c'est terminé
après 4 ans
alors
bien évidemment
un travail sur soi
si le travail d'une vie
mais
merci
[Applaudissements]
mais ce travail de ces fameux trois
objectifs que j'avais posé lors cette
première séance en septembre 2018 il y a
4 ans et ben ça y est ils sont accomplis
alors rappelez-vous le premier objectif
c'était de
de comprendre ce fameux schéma que je
reproduisais dans mes relations et de le
stopper ça on peut dire que ça complique
parce que vous cette personne dont je
vous parlais que j'avais rencontré aux
États-Unis la seule avec qui je pouvais
me sentir libre d'être moi-même et ben
il est devenu mon conjoint quelques
temps après
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième objectif c'était de savoir
prendre des décisions et alors vous vous
en doutez en étant chef d'entreprise
prendre des décisions trouver des
solutions aux problèmes font partie de
mon quotidien et le troisième objectif
qui était le plus gros morceau c'était
de soigner mes blessures et mon trauma
et c'est en ayant pris pleine conscience
en ayant mis des mots sur ce trauma et
ses blessures en les intégrant à mon
être que j'ai su apaiser mon cœur et mon
être
vous l'aurez compris en fait mon message
aujourd'hui c'est de vous dire
accueillons nos émotions
acceptons les et n'ayons pas peur de les
partager
aujourd'hui je souhaite vous laisser sur
une photo qui me représente au sommet du
Piton des Neiges c'est la première fois
il y a quelques années que je faisais la
sanction du Piton des Neiges et je
voulais vous laisser sur cette photo
parce que pour moi elle est pleine de
symboles et elle peut parler peut-être à
plusieurs personnes qui est que l'orgue
de cette ascension ou d'autres ascension
ou d'autres efforts on se sent
vulnérable et pourtant elle arrivait au
sommet on se sent fort et on se sent
vivant
alors voilà je suis vulnérable je suis
femme
je suis Agathe Agathe langaigne enchanté
et comme disait Simone de Beauvoir on ne
n'est pas femme on le devient merci